ce soir c'est votre tour jean claude
wiseler 1
ça se gâte
le temps se gâte beaucoup d'immeubles
pour nous dire que c'est très bon
[Musique]
y a que deux qui se dit [ __ ] quand je
pense que certains n'arrivent
je vous en prie
[Musique]
tu as voulu faire mouche
nous avons
[Musique]
voilà un jeu rigoureux ce soir ce soit
en ce sens dont j'imagine que c'était ce
à quoi sérieux y avait il y avait chez
pagis et dans le bouquin il y avait une
réplique me faisait beaucoup rire c'est
mourier gros mourir maigre la
différencient pour les porter
et saupiquet a dit l'important c'est ce
qu'il ya dans la boîte
[Rires]
ça va heureusement je suis pas
superstitieux non content c'est une
façon de conjurer le sort non il penser
de dix ans de plus la balle a alors
comme ça jean claude brialy vous êtes
mort
à un petit peu
c'est pour relancer votre carrière que
vous faites semblant d'être mort bages
et galamaz pme très très cher est ce que
c'est pour avoir un hommage aux césar
non je préférais avoir un hommage tout
court à notre dame de paris marc diab lé
vous êtes mort comment brut brutalement
en vous regardant la télévision
non il ya un problème quand il ya un
problème parce que maintenant toscan du
plantier mort vous bon vous êtes mort
aussi comment on va faire pour les
enterrements qui va prononcer les
oraisons funèbres a demandé à guy bedos
enfin je m'en fous et gvahim a toujours
envie de deux de dire quoi que ce soit
ou je suis trompé muet ce serait
absolument lamentable parce que je peux
pas dire deux mots je me trouve
tellement émouvant moi même
ouais qu'est-ce qu'il
chérissait l'entraîneur important
puisque je suis mort il est mort et
jean-claude m vous êtes mort qu'est ce
qui va nous casser les chemises que la
vie d'arletty maintenant
j'espère qu'elle va revenir vous tirez
pas des petits
savoir elle sait toucher comme hommage
vous préférez la rediffusion d'un
téléfilm sur france 2 ou un char à la
gay pride
je préférerais qu'on avoue ma relation
avec que fogiel
est-ce que
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour une
rue portera votre nom une place chéri
une place
faut-il rire de la mort nazis mais on
peut en mer il faut rire de l'amour tu
veux jouer ma poussée je te fasse une
petite place on va nous réduire l'un et
l'autre on va vous mettre dans des
petits bocaux tour le père et la mère la
chaîne
moi je
si c'est confortable un cercueil scène
on a mal aux fesses mais bon je vous le
dise moi
vous allez faire quoi dans votre
prochaine glisse jean claude enfin je
vais raconter des anges est pas le
diable
c'est bien ouais c'est un peu mais un
diable avec une toute petite queue
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu